another area of massive growth recently
has been the lightning network and every
single time i go and i look at these
statistics i'm personally just shocked
and i'm you know as bullish as they come
but the growth seems to be even
outpacing my expectations what are you
seeing here with the lightning network
public channel capacity yeah so i mean
the lightning network is not something
that gets talked about a lot in crypto
spheres it's kind of just this thing
that's that's being worked on under the
hood uh and a lot of these like you know
open source protocols uh apps different
like something like strike right where
it's almost abstracted away where you
don't even know you're using lightning
you're just scanning a qr code i think
that's the future and what what it
allows for is this monetary asset to be
settled basically instantaneously uh
anywhere in the world so jack muller's
is having a talk with the imf saying
this isn't even about bitcoin the asset
this is about bitcoin the network
uh and lightning the network which is a
layer layer two on top of a bitcoin just
being a superior monetary network
compared to anything the world's ever
seen and the reality is like almost no
one in the world understands that fact
yet uh that we can settle without
without really any counterparty risk we
can settle this absolutely scarce
monetary asset uh in a bearer type way
from peer-to-peer uh with no
intermediary with uh no counterparty and
with no really like risk of um you know
funds being seized or anything else that
you that you deal with on a traditional
kind of third party uh settlement
network or a third party like like a
visa paypal et cetera satoshi solved
that double spend problem and lightning
allowed for uh allows for this
instantaneous type settlement so it's
really exciting and a lot of really
smart people and engineers and founders
are building on top of this thing so you
know we're going to see you know more
countries adopt this as legal tender in
the future i think that's that's not
even a real bold prediction and you know
the medium of exchange type uh side of
bitcoin is really going to utilize
lightning network yeah it's pretty crazy
to think about uh the lightning network
uh without all the hype right for the
most part uh without tons of venture
backing um and uh it's just been
volunteers on the internet kind of
slowly but surely building a
peer-to-peer network of
you know what at now is probably tens of
thousands of people uh running these uh
lightning network nodes uh all
throughout the through the world and
really building a actual decentralized
system uh that has instantaneous
settlement
nearly free from a fee perspective
and at the end of the day is superior to
the legacy banking system right if i
want to send any amount of money uh even
if it is uh using my credit card at uh
the coffee shop etc there is not cash
finality there is not uh instantaneous
settlement there is not nearly free uh
you know from a fee perspective and so
this is superior technology and people
around the world are adopting it and i
think you see it in some of these
metrics that you're pointing out here
let's talk about uh exchange flows i
know you've been looking a lot at that
you've got the 30-day uh kind of
analysis of uh exchange flows what is
this telling us
yeah so um you know people try to get a
little too fancy with exchange flows and
use it as a top or a bottom indicator
and a lot of times it's not that simple
but
i think we can identify a few secular
trends here um one is that exchange
flows are basically persistently
negative for the most part so coins are
coming off exchanges except for a few
just type of you know big events we saw
uh with the china exodus uh and kind of
that liquidation event that happened
that mass liquidation event in the may
of 2021. saw a lot of coins flowing
exchanges we saw uh following the powell
kind of pivot uh and inflation's not
transitory in november we saw some coins
come on to exchange but really the trend
since the start of 2020 has been coins
are flowing out of exchanges by the
hundreds of thousands uh and just huge
numbers and so i think that trend is set
to continue uh and there will be you
know bumps in the road and you know
there'll be coins coming on exchanges at
certain times maybe the next time
all-time high breaks but the reality is
uh people are increasingly coming to
realize that bitcoin and the native kind
of properties of this asset that allow
you to self-custody it are really
important uh you know talking about
trudeau and canada earlier i i caught a
little bit of you guys before i came on
uh you know this this whole thing with
covet a lot of people are realizing it's
not about health uh and increasingly
it's just about control
and so you know money that can't be
seized money that's not a database entry
in someone else's database where you
know your political you know views don't
align with theirs well your money might
not be yours um so bitcoin in that sense
is more important than ever and
increasingly people are coming to
realize that so you know self-custody
your coins not your keys not your coins
it's the story of bitcoin yeah and it's
only gonna get louder and more prominent
i think uh we've got the illiquid supply
shock ratio here what is this telling us
yeah so shout out will clemente uh came
up with this one uh in in 2021 uh and on
chain what you can really see is it
quantifies the supply side of things uh
and and really this this primes uh or
sets the stage for for the demand side
so so price runs when the marginal
seller is exhausted and what we see here
is that just uh the marginal seller are
really just kind of this cohort of
stackers uh is is taking over and so
just continuing to eat away at that free
flow of supply uh diminishing that
available you know bitcoin to be sold on
the market uh every single day and so a
liquid supply this the supply shock
ratio quantifying uh the liquid supply
relative to the liquid and highly liquid
supply uh you know don't have to get too
much into the wheats with the
definitions but basically it's just
showing uh you know how much bitcoin is
being is is being held by its strong
hands uh relative to that kind of that
liquid supply and so it's it's as
attractive as it's as it's been since
the start of 2020 surpassing its 2021
highs
and so really what we're waiting for is
this big demand shift and i think we're
starting to see it um not even from the
inflation hedge narrative this digital
gold narrative the central bank dilution
narrative that we saw in in 2020 21 but
now we're seeing more so the census
resistance uh kind of effect play uh or
start to play out and so
really interesting time in bitcoin uh
but the demand side really what are the
supply side what this is showing is that
uh we're primed for for a big move when
that kind of demand shifts and comes in
a big way